okay with Avengers infinity war behind
us everyone's focus has now shifted the
future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and Marvel head Kevin Feige has been
particularly quiet about what movies
will be in phase four perhaps to avoid
any hints about who will survive the
next Avengers movie but one fan posted
on reddit a dream version of the
upcoming MCU line up with some
interesting title options
there's Avengers infinity crusade
spider-man learning curve Doctor Strange
nightmare
Thor god of thunder now these again man
in the wasp want them to be a bit
limited now again this is not real this
is fan made and compiled with fans
suggest the titles that have been
popping up on different social media for
all these movies now hopefully Black
Panther sequel will be better than a
black panther returns and Captain Marvel
if she gets a sequel have a better title
than Captain Marvel - but fans are
speculating that infinity crusade could
be the next title because in the it's a
title the Marvel comic storyline that
comes after the Infinity Gauntlet and
the infinity war and it follows Adam
warlock as he tries to like use the
gauntlet wisely I would say might been
in the actual events of infinity crusade
wouldn't maybe not make the best
Avengers for a movie but and in my
opinion the word crusade does evoke a
classic knights of the round table kind
of adventure that could be kind of fun
to see that it what title would you guys
like to see for the next Avengers movie
and maybe some of these others that are
I think infinity crusade is a fun title
but I don't know why they would have
kept it such a secret then cuz they've
really made we are weirdly big deal
about keeping the title and raps they've
said it's a spoiler basically expand
should be scared yeah so so I was
thinking like cuz I was actually
thinking if you're gonna go with a comic
series even though this one doesn't roll
off the tongue like infinity Greece say
does the Thanos imperative before yeah
because that was a big cosmic crossover
and and I think Venus is probably I mean
maybe big play a big part in this one
and I honestly wouldn't be surprised if
they continue taking cribbing from
Infinity Gauntlet that story if the
Avengers have to team up with Thanos
which I think would provide a lot of
like a lot of character tension because
obviously they have all the reasons in
the world he heard of yeah he just a few
just a couple so of people it that's the
only one I can think of that you'd why
would matter to keep it a secret on any
level yeah or maybe like infinity
sacrifice
or something like that or something
implying the death suggested because of
Scrolls and Captain Marvel secret
invasion but it's like there's no
possible way they've got too many other
things to wrap up from infinity war to
like dive into a whole nother crossover
event yeah you know agreed I'm just
looking at the themes of Hollywood at
the moment and it needs to have rise or
shadow yeah so think about this because
this is supposed to hurt so it could be
like Avengers Robert Downey jr. is not
coming back anymore now you can't stop
spider-man still just remember your
favorite character is real death I also
think it's just a middle finger
spider-man graduation yeah because it's
supposed to take place during his senior
year and they're gone with the school I
think that would be going for the third
one yeah learning curve I think would be
a really cool title for a second one
school related supposed to take place
during his senior year right cuz now
we've jumped ahead to the timeline super
confused right and the character is
currently a my age that's a good
question I was seeing an article was
talking about how do you after that
movie comes out like two months after
the next Avengers how do you advertise
for it considering and I think the
answer is you go for it
you spoil it or like the movie that you
promote maybe doesn't have Peter Parker
in it like I don't know it's weird to
have a spydra movie without spider-man
in it but that actually is a really good
he's been brought up like Donald Glover
played his uncle the reason why ultimate
spider-man shows up as pikas Peter dies
and that's been so Myles takes up the
mantle yeah Peter's gone buddy waiting
on Miles moving so that would be so that
would be confusing
yeah I wonder % Peter parks are going to
be back and I would it would shock me if
they don't just straight like oh you'd
be pretty shocking yeah
high club boy get lucky what is
happening in this movie he's flying the
lines oh boy oh boy
I like the god of thunder a title for
another Thor I would love to see a
fourth or maybe especially after
Ragnarok
I think Halle might be a better name
than God of Thunder Valhalla
you know using another kind of like Odin
as guardian well that means the
Valkyries will be there as well
we're just Valkyrie which that's got to
happen right the all-female team up
thing let's got to be in the world yeah
how'd it feel like five minutes it was
just a second because I rewatched it for
a third time this week and it was like
cool and it ends really fast and I was
like oh yeah it would be cool yeah let
us know what title pitches your titles
for what you would love to see in these
other ones yeah where as a reminder
subscribe to new rock stars for all of
our theories and predictions sometimes
they're right sometimes they're wrong
but they're always fun and yeah and
check out our other videos where we talk
about all the different Avengers
infinity war and future Avengers MCU
stuff thanks everybody